CBS News senior national security
analyst Fran Townsend is here she was a
homeland security and counterterrorism
adviser to President George W Bush
Fran good morning more angel I'd like to
start with this McCabe firing based on
your experience how unusual is this he
was fired for this supposedly this lack
of candor how big a deal of that just
what's your read on this so one it's
very unusual that you'd see the firing
of a Deputy Director it's not that it's
never happened before but it's very
unusual second the most serious offense
that you can accuse in terms of conduct
for an FBI official and in terms of
their character is a lack of candor
let's remember FBI agents make their
living by swearing under oath to the
truth of after affidavits the courts
then grant search warrants arrest
warrants on so a lack of candor is a
fireable offense if you if the
underlying conduct supports it and the
underlying a conduct here was
adjudicated not by President Trump but
by officials inside the FBI the the
Disciplinary officials inside the FBI so
those are career people right there are
two sets of career people right so first
it's the Department of Justice Inspector
General Mike Horowitz who is an Obama
appointee who also did the investigation
into fast and furious which was an
embarrassment to the Attorney General
Eric Holder at the time very
independent-minded has an independent
reporting line to Congress so he does an
investigation finds a lack of candor if
then goes for the FBI career officials
in the Office of Professional
Responsibility who agree with their
findings that there was a lack of candor
and agree with the recommendation of
firing the Trump administration has been
accused I heard over the weekend of
being vindictive and mean-spirited but
when you look at it the bottom line it
came from the FBI itself I think many
people were surprised by the harshness
of it and the timing especially the loss
of his pension could anything be done
about that
you know Gail I find the we don't
believe in collective punishment right
and so the people who are gonna pay the
price here are McCabe's wife and
children and that seems horribly unfair
I reminds me going back to the Robert
Hanssen case here's a man who was an FBI
agent who pled guilty to treason and as
part of his plea agreement what he
bargained for was that his wife receive
his pension
now I can't tell you how that got
executed and she got it but that was the
plea deal that they and the government
entered into because we don't believe in
collective punishment and so in some
ways it seems sort of tragic and unfair
to pull it's one thing to fire him for a
lack of candor assuming that that's
legitimate it's another thing to pull
the pension and I think that's really on
the surface so it does look vindictive
should we not take it that way well I
think we have to wait and see right the
other interesting thing Gail is that
they took this decision right because he
was going to officially be retired on
Sunday but that report has not been
completed and released yet now
presumably the deciding officials did
see it but it it feels vindictive just
because it was the timing of it in the
way it was man and as we mentioned this
is the first time over the weekend that
the president specifically went after
Muller in a tweet in your opinion is the
president laying the groundwork to
firing Bob Muller you know I don't I
don't think you necessarily have to
think it's laying the groundwork to fire
him because many in the Republican Party
have said that would be an act too far
but I think you have to take it at face
value this is the president so sort of
thrown what I'd call an inside pitch at
Muller saying remember I can this is
something I can do it's that sort of
threatening tone to it it's so offensive
frankly all right Fran Townsend to be
continued
thank you changes every day Thank You
Fran